et puis on vous parlait la semaine
dernière de toutes ces entreprises
québécoises qui ont été impliqués lors
de cette grande cérémonie d'ouverture à
sotchi show canada par exemple monsieur
labati qu'on avait en entrevue solotech
de montréal et bien maxence bilodeau
nous parle de la plus petite d'entre
elles petit mais lumineuse
c'est sur la foule que c'est fait le
décompte de l'ouverture des jeux de
sotchi plus tard à l'arrivée de la
délégation russe que voit-on les
couleurs du drapeau russe ce qui flotte
dans la foule
comment y est on arrivé en remettant à
chacun des quarante mille spectateurs un
récepteur à la forme de médailles
on peut à distance l'activé le flair
changer de couleur jacques spectateur
devient un pixel dans un immense écran
humain
c'est l'entreprise montréalaise pics mob
qui a réalisé ses effets lumineux x mob
a été créé en 2006 voici donc encore une
de ces jeunes entreprises spécialisées
dans l'organisation d'événements qui a
été inspiré par les succès du cirque du
soleil la sonde solaire sa fin de
trentaine d'années qui a du succès ça
fait une génération de jeunes qui ont vu
les spectacles du sert qui ont vu que
c'est possible d'avoir du succès man
show business le cirque du soleil leur a
d'ailleurs donné un solide coup de pouce
en 2010 en les engageant pour le
lancement d'un nouveau produit de
microsoft depuis xom a fait évoluer ses
produits ballons lumineux au spectacle
d'arcade fire ou encore de petits
hélicoptères qui deviennent des
bracelets lumineux
l'autre grand coups de pics mob viennent
d'avoir lieu c'était au super bowl au
spectacle de la mi temps
cette fois c'est 80000 spectateurs qui
ont été mis à contribution
on leur a des tous remis une tuque un
peu spécial est ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on
a intégré une carte électronique dans la
tuque qui est muni de trois petites led
et c est dans notre point noir que vous
voyez ici qui lui reçoit des ondes
infrarouges un peu comme votre
téléviseur comme le contrôle avec une
télécommande superb aux jeux olympiques
des événements à la visibilité
extraordinaire
pixman compte aujourd'hui 50 employés et
croit avoir devant elle un avenir
l'humide maxence bilodeau radio canada
mon frère